we also took a look at users search
which was pretty awful for a long time
you can find the people that you were
looking for and we've seen you know tens
of percentage points increases in
performance of that search feature since
we started actually tackling it it's
actually good collaboration with
Facebook they know search they've been
doing search for a long time we had half
a person's time on the weekends working
on search they have a team of dozens
working on search so be able to hook
into that platform has been great but
this is the very beginning there's a lot
more we need to do to make that news
discoverable to make what's going on in
the world accessible to people without
them having to go hunting for or find
out about it through a friend right now
most Instagram discovery happens very
organically through hey have you heard
of this amazing like the Nepal photo
project like now you know about it but
only because I transmitted it and the
obviously not a very sort of viral
experience to have you you know one on
one transmission that way well it's um
it's the only social service where the
only real way I have of adding people is
when a human being usually my partner
sometimes I don't know the tech CEO in
the green room says followed this and
yet it doesn't go away and yet people
are using it more